this is something that's really cool
regarding the holiday more so there was
one
Western journalist Gareth Jones
who was like all right something's not
adding up here so he was supposed to
take a train uh through Ukraine and he
got out early
and decided to start walking through the
countryside to go from Village to
Village
and I'll get to his story in a minute
right before we started recording
I got this book in the mail I ordered it
on November 28th from Great Britain it
was the only copy available on the whole
internet it's called experiences in
Russia 1931 it is anonymous
and it's uh Gareth Jones wrote the
introduction it was published by the
Alton Press in Pittsburgh it was
self-published and
she just says forward it just says by
the author
so it was the author who who went
alongside
um Gareth Jones was summoned by the name
of
Henry John Hines who was uh heir to the
Heinz Fortune
and you only know that if you start
looking the internet because his name's
not in with this book well I open this
book up right when I got it right before
we're taping
and it's signed by him and it took me a
second I'm like wait a minute who's the
signed by and it's h.j Hines because his
name was Jack Hines but it was Henry
John Hines from so this is I'm very
excited that I had this little miracle
in the mail
um Christmas miracle it's a Christmas
miracle we traveled they traveled
together they travel together so this
book's a diary of their travels why do
you think so few journalists
they was able to do what he did so there
were several reasons first of all if you
were a western journalist in the Soviet
Union you were under very strict uh uh
circumstances first of all you could be
deported any time you had no there was
no pretense that you have a right to be
a journalist in uh as especially as a
representative of a capitalist by which
they meant Western paper uh second it
was a complete nightmare getting your
paper your articles filed because you
had a sensor that you had to go through
and the censor's job who's life depended
on it was to make sure that your story
was advantageous to the Soviet Union or
at least neutral uh and they had all
sorts of techniques you know they could
spot they spied on you all the time they
followed you around because you know
you're a foreigner but also that sensor
had to answer to somebody so all the
sensor has to do is be like look I
having trouble with my supervisor and
the reporter could be like well can I
talk to supervisor it's like well I'm
sorry that's not possible and he's on
deadline but it's too bad bureaucracy
doesn't recognize the needs of deadlines
so
there was a big uh pressure a lot of
pressure on Western journalists to have
to get through this net and that's
literally constant you know every story
it's going to be a fight so at a certain
point you're just going to be like all
right and you're going to pre-censor
yourself you know if you know all right
if I include this it's not going to get
through what are you supposed to do I
think human beings are naturally and
also a lot of these journalists were
pro-soviet they thought this is the
Society of the future at least
everyone's trying to make it a better
country for everyone not like back home
with a poor poor slip between the cracks
uh we got to do what we can to make this
work
and
you know there was a lot of I don't want
to say conspiracy but within the
industry there was a consensus that the
Stalin was the good guy and we were if
not the bad guy certainly not as good uh
in certain regards so when this news of
the famine started percolating all the
other Western journalists besides Gareth
Jones and Malcolm muggeridge were saying
this isn't true it's nothing that they
haven't seen before the paper that took
the lead in this was New York Times with
their guy Walter Durante who had
previously won a Pulitzer and had
interviewed Stalin which is a enormously
rare honor for a Westerner
um and he because he has so much
experience covering uh Russia and the
Soviet Union he basically took the lead
and other people followed his lead you
know he was kind of the dean of the
press Corps in Russia and he made a
point and the thing there's so many
quotes I have from him
um where he's not only denying that this
Mass starvation is happening he's also
going after journalists who are
questioning the narrative and he you
know he says things like look this is
nothing that the Russians haven't
experienced before they're simply
tightening their belts and it's like you
only have to tighten your belt when you
don't have enough food it's not like
they started a new exercise regimen and
now their body Fat's dropping that's why
would someone tie their belt so that was
one and there the New York Times had a
13 page article big headline Russians
hungry not starving and he went after
Jones he went after uh muggerage I
believe although he did go after
Margaret but the point being that this
is just propaganda from people who want
the Soviet Union to fail you know they
don't understand what they're building
here uh you know he had so many excuses
like oh you know the reason all these
Russians are supposedly leaving their
villages to go to the cities isn't
because there's no food it's because
they're nomadic it's tradition they go
from town to town looking for new
experiences and it's just you know at a
certain point and I think it's 19 31
where he was eventually like or 51
rather I don't remember he was like oh
well uh I guess I was kind of wrong and
it's like he's like any journalist worth
his salt can admit when he's wrong and
it's like well were you worth your salt
because you sure you he explicitly said
there's no point in sending out
journalists to look for themselves I've
been through the countryside and
everyone's fine and it's just that the
loudest people are making noise whereas
everyone else is doing the work and and
you know trying and and this isn't about
famine but it's about Western skeptical
about collectivization which is just
simply a new way of farming and yeah it
was anyway farming and the results were
by Design and also accidentally
absolutely catastrophic
how how hard was it
to see the truth at that time do you
think do you think that was a mistake
that that's understandable to make as a
journalist if my job as a journalist
I have two bosses if I'm in Moscow I've
got my reporter in New York or London or
whatever but I've got my sensor here and
he is making sure I have
a house the department he makes sure I
have food he makes Drive access to
dignitaries he's my lifeline if I piss
him off I'm on the next plane out of
town so is that enough is that enough to
uh
slowly suffocate the Integrity of a
journalist I don't think it was slow at
all and it was clearly enough and
because what are they going to disagree
with that I just I I I think the failure
of integrity
has to come from New York on the New
York on the American side that it's just
the flock of fish or whatever that all
move in the same narrative right
I think journalists
would like to be the kind of people that
have integrity so if they are conscious
of sacrificing their own Integrity they
wouldn't do it if they're conscious of
an act that's doing it they wouldn't do
it so it has to happen like a lobster
slowly boiling no I think it happens
when everyone else is it's a it's a
Greek chorus right it's a chorus but
that's exactly that's right so it's not
about the ACT but they will I mean I've
talked to no journalists where I get the
sense that they will sell their soul for
access
because that's their job
is it though because what they do what
journalists do I've seen American
journalists they take a huge amount of
pride for having gotten the interview
whatever that is the the Putin interview
and
first of all they they're gleaming
they're they're glowing with pride it
seems like they're always showing off to
the other journalists back in America so
they're growing up like showing off like
look I got the access you didn't and
second thing they're doing when they
show up to that interview is they ask
all the questions that signal to the
other journalists that we're on the same
side they ask the most generic
aggressive questions to which they know
the answers
to to they they just they want to they
want to basically get the access and ask
the quote-unquote hard-hitting questions
that they know will not be answered and
this is this is the entire Machinery of
it it's not it's that's modern
journalism and I suppose at that time
it was worse it was worse they weren't
even doing the hard-hitting the uh the
display of hard-hitting questions right
because these PR pieces think about what
High status that is if I'm an American
journalist in Moscow I'm allowed in this
secretive country I'm you know I'm the
I'm the guy who's very privileged to
have access to live in Moscow and tell
Americans which we're all fascinated
about this new Society of the future
what it's like and as soon as I kind of
uh start questioning the narrative I'm
gonna get kicked out and humiliated very
publicly I thought you were in Moscow
what am I supposed to say so you know
they uh Eugene Lyons
was you know he's one of the heroes in
the book he was a young communist and I
think it was United press he was working
for they sent him there and when he went
there he's like oh this is not what I
thought it was going to be like this is
horrible and he's he's turned very
heavily against it but he talks about
how they would write one thing and say
another thing and then think another
thing and each of those steps was just
more and more like kind of lying in
terms of maintaining your sanity and
maintaining your narrative